.
Das war nicht so geplant, v.a. nicht
auf der anderen Seite der Welt.
Dass er Marokkaner
und nicht Schweizer ist -
das ist klar, das ist etwas,
was mir sehr attraktiv scheint.
Eigentlich keine Liebe auf den ers-
ten Blick. Aber schon Faszination.
* Romantische Musik:
"Take My Hand" von Martin Villiger
und Adrian Stern *
# Take my hand. Take me anywhere,
as long as you are there.
# Take my hand.
(Liebe fragt nicht nach dem Pass.)
(Liebe kann grenzenlos sein.)
(Liebe nimmt uns an der Hand -
und schon sind wir hin und weg.)
(Das sind Schweizer Liebesgeschichten
aus aller Welt.)
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Herzschlag *
(In diesem interessanten Haus
direkt am Strand
wohnt Nicole seit zwei Jahren.)
(Vielleicht
kommt sie Ihnen bekannt vor.)
(Nicole Pavlin
hat vor über zehn Jahren
beim Schweizer Fernsehen
verschiedene Sendungen moderiert.)
(Dann hat sie ihre Koffer gepackt
und ist in die Welt hinausgezogen.)
* Meeresrauschen *
Ja, das ist ...
Das tut gut.
Das tut wirklich gut.
Manchmal hüpfe ich rein -
wenn ich Zeit habe.
(Als Chefin eines eigenen Hotels
und Mutter der siebenjährigen Lila
ist Zeit aber ein seltenes Gut.)
Lila?
Guten Morgen.
Jalla.
Voilà, komm.
Okay?
Komm.
Gehst du schon mal vor?
Papa kommt.
Geh schon mal ins Restaurant.
- I don't wanna go.
Wartest du auf Papa?
Okay.
(Seit elf Jahren ist Rachid
der Mann an Nicoles Seite.)
(Als sie sich kennenlernten,
war er Polizeiinspektor in
der marokkanischen Stadt Essaouira.)
Tschüss.
Bye, bye, Mama.
Bye, bye.
- Bye.
* Herzschlag *
Es war nicht Liebe auf den
ersten Blick, sondern einfach ...
"Das ist dein Mann."
Oder: "Ich bin seine Frau."
Aber es war einfach
eine Klarheit da.
Und die Liebe kam erst danach,
mit dem Kennenlernen.
Wir waren nicht mehr die Jüngsten.
Wir hatten auch keinen Rucksack.
Wir waren nicht verheiratet,
hatten damals keine Kinder.
Mit 40 ist das ziemlich selten.
* Entspannte Musik *
(Hierhin also hat es
die Schweizerin Nicole Pavlin
und den Marokkaner
Rachid Hirach-Idrissi verschlagen:
auf Sansibar,
die Insel mit dem klingenden Namen,
die zu Tansania gehört.)
(Gestern Abend
habe ich sie nur kurz begrüsst.)
(Erst jetzt
nehme ich so richtig wahr,
in was für einem Paradies
ich hier gelandet bin.)
Ich komme einfach frech herein.
Das ist euer Privathaus?- Ja.
Da bin ich noch gar nie gewesen.
Ich habe erst das Hotel ...
- Es ist nicht für jeden zugänglich.
Obwohl wir
direkt neben den Gästen sind.
Darf ich es anschauen?- Klar.
- Darf ich so frech sein?
- Wo zuerst?
Gut, das ist ...
(Französisch) Ist das die Küche?
Ja,
normalerweise wäre das die Küche.
Was ist das?
Das ist ein Jahr Arbeit.
So eine Küche
würde man sich wünschen.
D.h., du musst nie selber kochen.
- Richtig.
Ich koche gerne -
wenn ich Zeit habe - für Freunde.
Aber das alltägliche Kochen
ist für mich Horror.
Esst ihr im Restaurant?
Wir können immer
im Restaurant essen.
Manchmal brauchen wir etwas Distanz.
Dann können wir aber bestellen.
* Entspannte Gitarrenklänge *
Ich bin zu Hause,
wenn meine Sachen da sind.
Kunst, das muss da sein.
Dann fühle ich mich auch daheim.
Er ist sich das nach zwölf Jahren
gewohnt.
Es ist immer dabei. Auch in Marokko.
- Ja.
Das hat ein Freund gemalt.
Frauenkörper gefallen mir sowieso.
Ich finde es schön,
wenn es in die Natur zurückgeht.
(Französisch) Und dir, gefällt das?
Nein.
Aber es ist ihr Bild.
Mir gefällt es nicht.
Keine Ahnung, was es bedeuten soll.
Es interessiert mich
aber auch nicht.
Komm, wir gehen rauf. Ist okay.
* Entspannte Musik *
(Seit elf Jahren sind Nicole
und Rachid verheiratet.)
(Erst im zweiten Anlauf
hat es geklappt.)
(Der erste Versuch platzte
wegen des marokkanischen Königs.)
Ihr konntet nicht heiraten -
wegen des Königs?
Ja.
Weisst du, ein Sicherheitsmann
der Polizei darf nur ausreisen,
wenn der König im Land ist.
Also, jetzt langsam:
Ihr habt in der Schweiz geheiratet.
Genau.
Du warst in der Schweiz.
Und ihr wolltet heiraten.
Dann standest du vor dem Altar ...
Vor dem Zivilstandesamt.
Ehrlich? Und er kam nicht?
Er konnte nicht kommen.
Er versuchte, auszureisen.
Dafür brauchst du ein Papier
vom König, unterschrieben.
Das hatte er nicht,
da der König in Frankreich war.
Ich sagte ihm, er solle es
einfach versuchen am Flughafen.
Sie nahmen ihn raus, ins Büro.
Er wollte illegal ausreisen -
obwohl er nicht durfte,
da der König ausser Land war.
Sie sagten: "Wenn du nichts sagst,
haben wir dich nicht gesehen."
"Geh einfach subito nach Hause. "
Er hätte im Knast landen können.
- L'histoire du mariage. Ouais.
Ich sagte:
"Gut, wir versuchen es nochmals."
"In drei Monaten ist mein 40."
"Machen wir heute
mein Geburtstagsfest
und an meinem 40. heiraten wir."
Das ist auch der Tag
der Thronbesteigung des Königs.
Deshalb wussten wir, dass er da in
Marokko sein würde. So klappte es.
Wir haben es geschafft.
Da sieht man es.
Die Fotos sind schon etwas vergilbt.
Mit dem Salzwasser in der Luft
verfärbt sich alles.
Ah, der rosarote Filter?
- Ja.
Und dann habt ihr Ja gesagt?
-  Genau.
Nein,
wir hatten ja schon unterschrieben.
Da kannst du Ja oder Nein sagen.
Es macht keinen Unterschied mehr.
Aber sie hat uns gefragt.
Ich mache nur Spass.
* Entspannte Gitarrenklänge *
* Sie unterhalten sich leise
auf Französisch. *
* Herzschlag *
Angefangen hat es eigentlich,
als ich mal seine Facebookseite
entdeckt habe.
Also seine Reiseseite.
Dort war das Matterhorn abgebildet.
Ich fand das spannend,
denn die Seite war auf Schwedisch.
Ich habe dieses Matterhornbild
geliked.
Ich hoffe, ich erzähle dasselbe.
Ich glaube, es war - ich bin
nicht sicher - das Gipfelfoto.
Das Gipfelfoto. Dachte ich's mir.
Da war dann ein Kommentar von ihr.
So ging es hin und her.
So begann es.
* Sanfte Klänge *
(Florence und Niklas
sind verheiratet,
führen aber zurzeit
noch eine Fernbeziehung.)
(Aus verschiedenen Gründen.
Dazu kommen wir später.)
Do you wanna come with her, Leo?
(Heute müssen sie wieder
für einige Wochen Abschied nehmen.)
Wir haben mal gesagt:
"Irgendwann wird es Routine."
Aber wir haben das Gefühl, es werde
immer schlimmer und nicht Routine.
Wir sprachen gerade heute Morgen
davon.
Ja,
es sind nicht die schönen Momente.
V.a. weil wir wissen,
dass es wieder einen Monat dauert
bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ja.
I said we never get used to this.
Ach, es bleibt ein Mist.
Aber so ist es nun mal.
- Ja.
Wir werden täglich miteinander
sprechen, Nachrichten schreiben
und wieder Tschüss sagen.
Aber wir haben dafür auch
sehr viele glückliche Augenblicke.
Jedes Mal, wenn wir
uns wieder Hallo sagen können.
Das gleicht das ständige Tschüss-
sagen wieder ein bisschen aus.
That's right.
- Maybe that's the strategy.
That we know
in a month it's always ... Yeah.
This very happy moment, again.
Ja.
- Ja.
Time to go?
- Time to go.
Bye, baby.
Tschüss.
Bis bald.
Sei ein guter Junge.
Gib ihm nicht zu viel Futter.
Tu ich gar nicht.
* Sie lacht. *
Das ist das dicke Fell.
You're okay, Leo.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
(Das war lange bevor der Flugverkehr
in ganz Europa
wegen des Coronavirus
zusammengebrochen ist.)
(Dass es für Florence und Niklas
bald viel schwieriger werden würde,
sich zu sehen,
ahnten sie da noch nicht.)
Bye.
Love you.
- Love you.
Hello.
So lange
mit jemandem zusammen zu sein,
ist nicht schlecht.
Zehn Jahre verheiratet.
- Wir arbeiten zusammen.
Wir schlafen zusammen.
Wir frühstücken zusammen.
Das ist, wie wenn wir statt
zwölf Jahre 24 Jahre zusammen wären.
Man kann die Zeit
eigentlich verdoppeln.
Ja, das ist eine Challenge.
Ja.
* Meeresrauschen *
(Seit zwölf Jahren
sind Nicole und Rachid zusammen.)
(Die Romantik
überlassen sie inzwischen jenen,
die ihre Flitterwochen
bei ihnen verbringen.)
Wir legen unten Blumen
auf die Einzelbetten -
was natürlich keinen Sinn ergibt,
weil die sicher nicht im Einzelbett
schlafen, die Honeymooners.
Oben sollte auch alles dekoriert
sein. Wir schauen nach. Let's go.
Nice.
Two swans, kissing.
Yeah, it's nice.
- Do you like it?
Yeah, I like it very much.
- You're welcome.
Ich mag's nicht kitschig.
Simpel, mit einer Symbolik dahinter,
fertig.
Okay.
(Auf Sansibar ist bis auf die beiden
Regenzeiten im Frühling und Herbst
eigentlich immer Saison.)
(Deshalb können Nicole und Rachid
bis zu 40 Einheimischen
fast rund ums Jahr einen Job geben.)
(Kaum ein Tag vergeht, ohne dass neue
Gäste im Hotel Baladin einchecken.)
Hallo. Du bist die Lea, oder?
- Hi, ja genau.
Hallo. Freut mich.
- Freut mich.
Du bist die Nicole?
- Ich bin Nicole. Schön.
Gut, also ... Dann begrüssen
wir euch mit einem Welcome Drink.
* Entspannte Klänge *
Wir haben uns sehr wohlgefühlt.
War toll, auch mit den Kindern.
Oh, danke schön. Vielen Dank.
(Nicole ist die Hoteldirektorin.)
(Sie hat auch einen Teil ihres
Ersparten ins Projekt investiert.)
(Mit Folgen, die sie und Rachid
nicht vorhergesehen haben.)
(Die lokalen Behörden wussten
nicht so recht, wie damit umgehen,
dass Nicole als Frau
das Geld bringt.)
(Als Investorin
war sie sofort willkommen.)
(Aber ihr Mann hat bis heute
keine dauerhafte
Aufenthaltsbewilligung bekommen.)
(Wäre er der Investor, hätte
seine Frau sofort eine bekommen.)
(Auch für die Beziehung
war das nicht immer einfach.)
Wie sieht es jetzt mit
deiner Aufenthaltsbewilligung aus?
Die Situation ist, dass ich
nun schon seit zwei Jahren warte.
Deux ans?
- Ouais.
Aber Nicole
hat die Bewilligung bereits?
Ja, weil sie Investorin
und Miteigentümerin des Hotels ist.
Deshalb ging es bei ihr schneller.
Wie ist der aktuelle Stand?
Hat sich jetzt etwas geändert?
Die Arbeitsbewilligung habe ich.
Es sieht aus, als bekäme ich
nun die Aufenthaltsbewilligung.
Sicher?
Ich will keine Zahlen nennen.
Die Chancen stehen bei ...
... 55 %.
Et ça, c'est pas vraiment ...
* Herzschlag *
Ganz am Anfang,
v.a. als ich ihn kennengelernt hatte
und sagte, er komme in die Schweiz,
sagten viele: "Bist du wahnsinnig?"
Ich wohnte damals noch
bei meinen Eltern, bis wir auszogen.
Sie sagten: "Ja, aber ...
Du hast ihn drei Tage gesehen."
"Jetzt kommt der
einfach in eure Wohnung."
Da dachten schon einige,
dass das
eh nur so ein Ferienflirt sei.
(Es war
definitiv mehr als ein Ferienflirt.)
Ja, wir wohnen schön.- Ja.
- Und jetzt haut ihr ab.
(Cahil Parks und Martina Stutz
lernten sich in Australien kennen.)
(Was als Ferienliebe begann,
ist längst ernst geworden.)
(Kurz nach der Hochzeit
zog Cahil zu Martina in die Schweiz.)
(Und er hat sich bestens eingelebt.)
(Auch die Zwillingsschwester,
Melanie, und ihr Freund, Sandro,
haben ihn ins Herz geschlossen.)
(Die Idylle auf dem Buochserhorn wäre
perfekt, wenn Martina und Melanie
einander nicht bald
Tschüss sagen müssten.)
(Für die Zwillingsschwestern
nicht einfach.)
Wir freuen uns auch darauf,
sie zu besuchen.
Wir haben gestern
den Flug gebucht.
Es ist gut zu wissen,
wann wir sie wiedersehen.
Das macht den Abschied einfacher.
- Ja, das macht es einfacher.
Wenn man etwas in Aussicht hat.
Neun Monate.
Neun Monate sind es.
- Dann sehen wir uns wieder.
(Zum zweiten Mal innert zwei Jahren
müssen Cahil und Martina abwägen:
Wer geht Kompromisse ein?)
(Und was sind sie bereit,
für ihre Liebe zurückzulassen?)
Irgendwie gebe ich auf, was für mich
das Allerwichtigste ist im Leben:
Familie und Freunde.
Freunde und Familie sind natürlich
auch für mich das Wichtigste.
Aber mein Glück aufzugeben mit
meinen Hobbys und meinem Lifestyle -
okay, es war zwar
nur für zwei Jahre.
Still, you gave it up.
- Of course.
Wenn du gesagt hättest: "Komm
in die Schweiz und bleib für immer",
ich weiss nicht,
was ich gesagt hätte.
* Herzschlag *
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
(Einige Monate vor der Abreise
haben Cahil und Martina
die eigene Wohnung gekündigt
und sind bei ihren Eltern in Buochs
untergekommen.)
(Und man merkt schnell:
Auch wenn sich die ganze Familie
für das Glück der beiden freut,
leicht wird
der Abschied niemandem fallen.)
* Leise Gespräche, Lachen *
* Herzschläge *
Sie hat etwas vor sich,
alles neu, immer wieder neu.
Ich glaube,
dass es für sie einfacher ist.
Es ist aber trotzdem
genau gleich schwierig.
V.a. in dem Moment, in dem sie geht.
Der Abschied am Flughafen,
der wird sicher nicht einfach.
Und ...
(Melanie) Oh, nein, Papi.
Bei uns sind die Emotionalen
v.a. die Männer.
Die sind bei mir gelagert.
Du kannst eine Pause machen.
- Nein.
Als ich ihnen in die Augen geschaut
habe, habe ich gesagt: "Das ist es."
Das kann gar nicht schiefgehen.
Deshalb stehen wir
komplett dahinter.
Och.
Oh.
- Ist so.
So süss.
Komm, gib mir einen hug.
(Das war im Januar 2020.)
(Da hätte niemand gedacht,
dass in den nächsten Monaten
alles ganz anders würde
als geplant.)
* Herzschlag *
Er ist der Mann, den ich mir
immer vorgestellt habe.
Ein richtiger Mann.
Er ist gross, er ist klug, er
ist kräftig, er ist selbstbewusst.
Er ist gebildet.
Eben.
Wer ist von euch
die grösste Wasserratte?
Vermutlich ich.
Ich bin ausgebildete Divemaster.
Sicher? Ehrlich?
- Ja.
* Fröhliche,
gezupfte Gitarrenklänge *
(Trotz Nicoles Liebe zum Wasser
sind solche Familienausflüge selten.)
(Das Hotel nimmt beide in Beschlag.)
Wir müssen uns aufteilen.
Bin ich weg, muss er da sein
und umgekehrt.
Entweder habe ich Lila an dem Tag
oder er.
Es ist eine Challenge.
Habt ihr das gewusst?
Der Preis, hierherzukommen,
geht auf Kosten des Familienlebens.
Es war vorher schon so.
Er war Polizeiinspektor,
arbeitete auf Abruf
und hatte auch Nachtdienst.
So viel hat sich nicht geändert -
ausser dass wir
für das Gleiche arbeiten.- Ja.
Bei meiner Arbeit
war es wirklich zu viel -
manchmal bis zu 16 Std. pro Tag.
Auch hier arbeite ich viel -
von morgens früh bis abends,
wenn ich abschliesse.
Das zwingt mich manchmal,
darüber nachzudenken,
was ich hier überhaupt mache.
Es ist genau das Gleiche.
Ich habe gekündigt, Freunde und
Familie in Marokko zurückgelassen.
Aber das hier hattest du nicht.
Das war für dich ein grosses Opfer?
Für Nicole ist das hier der Traum.
Am Strand zu leben
und ein Hotel zu führen.
Für dich nicht?
- Nein, mein Traum war das nicht.
Aber wir hatten einen Deal,
Monsieur.
* Rachid lacht. *
Wir hatten einen Deal.
Ich sagte: "Ich will das machen."
Er sagte: "Ich will eine Familie."
Nein, nein, nein.
Das kann ich so nicht akzeptieren.
Non, non, non.
Und zuerst kam Lila.
* Rachid lacht. *
Achtung,
ich verstehe Schweizerdeutsch.
Zuerst kam Lila
und ein paar Jahre später
hatten wir endlich den Strand.
(Da gibt es offenbar noch
ein wenig Interpretationsspielraum.)
Wäh!
(Klar ist aber,
die Familie ist mit Lila komplett.)
(Einen Strand haben sie auch,
inkl. einem tropischen Aquarium,
das einlädt abzutauchen und
allfällige Misstöne zu vergessen.)
* Friedliche Klänge *
* Herzschlag *
* Bellen *
(Seit zwei Jahren
ist Niklas aus Schweden
die grosse Liebe von Florence.)
(Solange sie aber noch
im Kanton Solothurn wohnt,
gilt mindestens genauso viel
Aufmerksamkeit ihren Hunden.)
(Insgesamt sieben Vierbeiner
besitzt sie.)
(Mann) Wir haben gesagt,
wir machen den Parcours.
Wir machen Fünfergruppen,
hier: drei, fünf.
Ihr könnt auf diese Seite.
Hopp, hopp, hopp.
- (Mann) Du kannst noch aufholen.
Hopp, hopp, hopp, Max. Komm.
Hast du Wurst,
um Max vorne durchzuziehen?
(Früher oder später,
wenn Florence ganz zu Niklas zieht,
wandern auch die Hunde
nach Schweden aus.)
Nein! Nein!
Die ist weg.
- Nein, noch nicht. Schau! Schau!
* Florence lacht. *
Ich bekomme keinen Kaffee.
* Lachen *
Es gibt auch Momente,
in denen man beinahe zweifelt.
In denen man denkt: Wie ist es an
dem Tag, an dem ich wirklich gehe?
Wie wird das sein?
Da macht man sich schon Gedanken.
Oder wenn etwas in Schweden ist,
bei dem ich mich frage,
ob ich damit klarkomme.
Aber das sind kurze Sequenzen,
die sehr schnell wieder ...
im Hinterkopf sind.
(Mit den Hunden haben die Zweifel
übrigens gar nichts zu tun -
im Gegenteil.)
Eigentlich wäre das der Grund dafür,
dass wir sehr gerne
nach Schweden möchten.
Wir haben
ein Grundstück im Wald gekauft.
Das wäre mit den Hunden ideal.
Der Grund, weshalb ich
noch hier bin, ist meine Tochter,
Noya.
Sie wurde im Oktober 17.
Sie ist noch in der Ausbildung.
Und ...
Sie ist ...
Sie hat ein psychisches Problem,
das es ihr erschwert,
im Alltag zurechtzukommen.
Deshalb möchte ich
noch da sein für sie.
(Es eilt sowieso nicht
mit dem Umzug.)
(Florence und ihre Tochter
haben noch Zeit füreinander.)
(Niklas hat
gerade erst damit begonnen,
auf dem Grundstück in Schweden
ein Haus zu bauen.)
(Bis das für Florence
und ihre Tiere bezugsbereit ist,
dürfte es noch eine Weile dauern.)
* Bellen und Knurren *
Mit sieben, acht Hunden
entspreche ich
nicht unbedingt der Norm.
Wenn jemand sagen würde,
er möchte gerne mit mir
zusammen sein und alles,
aber von sieben
müsse ich fünf weggeben,
dann müsste ich sagen:
"Sorry, nein. Das mache ich nicht."
Das klingt etwas hart, ich weiss.
Aber das sind für mich Lebewesen,
sie gehören auch zur Familie.
Keine Liebe der Welt könnte
für mich diesen Verlust auffangen.
* Sanfte Gitarren-
und Klavierklänge *
(Niklas Wibring wohnt in Jönköping
im Süden von Schweden.)
(Verheiratet war er zwar nie,
hat aber zwei erwachsene Kinder:
Linus und Enya.)
(Und eben:
seit Kurzem auch einen Hund.)
* Lachen *
Das ist ein Testhund.
Ich hatte noch nie einen Hund.
Dann traf ich diese Frau -
und die hat 200-300 von denen.
Und weil sie irgendwann
hierherziehen
und mind. 268 Hunde mitbringen wird,
will ich nun versuchen,
mich daran zu gewöhnen.
Das ist Leo, den ich zu Testzwecken
von ihr mitgenommen habe.
Den blinden Leo.
Er ist schon ein Jahr bei mir.
Wir haben es gut miteinander.
Solange er nicht in mein Bett kommt.
Ich habe nämlich
eine leichte Hundeallergie.
Linus und Enya,
könnt ihr kurz zum Hund schauen?
(Diese Hundeallergie
hindert Niklas aber nicht daran,
fleissig an der gemeinsamen Zukunft
zu arbeiten - im Gegenteil.)
(Es zeigt höchstens,
wie ernst er es meint.)
(Sein ganzes Erspartes
hat er genommen,
um für sich und Florence
ein Traumhaus im Wald zu bauen.)
Natürlich, wenn sie
in einem halben Jahr sagen würde,
dass sie nun doch nicht komme,
wäre das schlimm.
Ich wäre -
wie soll ich sagen -
finanziell ruiniert.
Some of this.
(Seine Kinder hat Niklas übrigens
nicht gross miteinbezogen,
als er mit Florence Pläne
für ein neues Leben geschmiedet hat.)
(Auch von der Hochzeit
haben sie nur indirekt erfahren.)
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
* Herzschlag *
Etwas regt ihn furchtbar auf:
Lila und ich lieben ...
z.B. Schinken und Cervelat.
Das ist halt Schweinefleisch.
Und das findet er überhaupt nicht
cool, wenn ich das zulasse.
Sie ... Klar, als Kind,
das ist etwas, das ...
... schmeckt.
Und da gibt es
manchmal ziemlich Streit.
Quoi?
- Le jambon.
Ja, das mag ich gar nicht.
Das hat
mit gegenseitigem Respekt zu tun.
Es geht nicht um Religion,
sondern darum, dass ich
mitbestimmen will, was sie isst.
Aber sie liebt es so.
Das ist mir egal. Es geht
um Erziehung. Sie ist ein Kind.
Jetzt entscheiden wir noch,
was sie isst.
Ich mag diese Regeln nicht.
Bitte nicht mehr.
Wir brauchen Salami gar nicht erst
aufzutischen, wenn sie da ist.
Genau,
wir machen es nur noch versteckt.
* Entspannte Musik *
(Das Hotel am Strand von Sansibar
war nicht nur Nicoles Idee,
sie hat es auch selbst mitaufgebaut.)
Mit welchen Gefühlen
läufst du da täglich herum?
Manchmal muss man sich schon sagen:
"Mein Gott!"
Dass wirklich ich es war,
die mitgeholfen hat
beim Buddeln,
Graben und Streichen und ...
Wünschst du dir
etwas mehr Anerkennung?
Z.B. Rachid -
sieht er, weiss er, was du ...
Ja, aber er hat sich während
des Bauens völlig ausgeklinkt,
das war nicht sein Ding.
- Ja.
Er hat zu sich geschaut,
er musste sich finden.
Was macht das mit der Beziehung?
Ihr seid euch nicht näher gekommen.
Nein, am Anfang
war es recht schwierig.
Er war sehr unzufrieden.
Es sei nicht seins,
er sei nicht der Strandtyp.
Er fand, in Marokko sei alles
einfacher, was vielleicht stimmt,
denn wir sind in Schwarz-
und nicht in Nordafrika.
Ich sagte dann,
wir müssten das durchziehen.
"Wir eröffnen und wenn es das
nicht ist, können wir wieder gehen."
Wenn ich meinen Auftrag quasi
erfüllt, das Ding aufgestellt habe,
dann kann ich auch loslassen.
Das hast du ihm gesagt?- Ja,
aber er musste sagen, wohin ...
Ja.
- ... und was wir dann machen.
Ab die Post.
- Genau.
(Zwei Lebensentwürfe
unter einen Hut zu bringen,
ist auch im vermeintlichen Paradies
nicht einfach.)
(Rachid, ehemaliger Polizeiinspektor
aus Essaouira in Marokko,
brauchte einen Moment, um sich mit
den neuen Umständen anzufreunden.)
* Entspannte Musik *
Das war nicht dein Traum,
sondern jener von Nicole.
Warum hast du dich
trotzdem entschieden,
hier ein neues Leben anzufangen?
Erstens wollte ich sowieso
aus dem Polizeidienst aussteigen.
Zweitens bin ich jemand,
der nicht allzu lange nachdenkt
vor einer Entscheidung.
Si je vais reflechir trop,
peut-être je vais dire non.
Und drittens wusste ich,
dass Nicole eine starke Frau ist,
die mir auch helfen würde,
die ersten Schritte zu machen.
* Wellenrauschen,
Stimmen im Hintergrund *
(Dass Nicole die Chefin
und damit Rachids Vorgesetzte ist,
hat sich auch
auf ihre Beziehung ausgewirkt.)
(Die neue Rollenverteilung und
seine Abhängigkeit von Nicole waren
für den ehemaligen marokkanischen
Polizeiinspektor nicht einfach.)
(Auch darum nimmt er heute
einen neuen Anlauf,
um seinen Status zu verbessern.)
You looked to the other side
before you crossed.
We can go, we can go.
Wow.
Hallo, Mr Eric.
Wie geht's? Gut?
Ist Mr Ali hier?
- Yeah, Mr Ali's here.
Können wir rein?
Guten Abend, Mr Ali.
Wie geht's?
(Herr Ali hat endlich geschafft,
was Rachid seit zwei Jahren
Kampf mit den Behörden
erfolglos probiert hat:
Die Bewilligung ist bereit.)
But ... Did you call somebody today
or did you send somebody?
(Der Drucker sei kaputt gewesen,
deshalb habe es länger gedauert,
sagt Herr Ali.)
(Und übergibt Rachid
das langersehnte Dokument.)
... printing, then they gave me.
Can I have a look
at my residence permit?
And this is ...
... valid for two years?
For two years, until '22.
- Okay.
Thank you very much, Mr Ali.
Schön.
Dann können wir jetzt feiern.
Vielen Dank.
Besuchen Sie uns mit Ihrer Familie.
Kommen Sie zum Mittagessen
oder Abendessen.
(Wieso jetzt plötzlich
alles so gut geklappt hat,
werden wir
wahrscheinlich nie erfahren.)
(Ein Schelm, wer Böses dabei denkt.)
Right. Let's go.
No.
* Rachid lacht. *
Sorry, let's go now.
- Run, run.
* Entspannte Musik *
Vraiment?
Cool.
Félicitations. Wow.
- Merci.
Wow, wow, wow. Cool.
* Sie seufzt erleichtert. *
A toi. A nous.
A nous. A la résidence.
Vive la Tanzanie.
* Applaus *
Thank you.
- Merci.
Wow.
(Nicole war die treibende Kraft
für das Hotelprojekt in Sansibar.)
(Rachid hat wohl oder übel
mitgezogen.)
(Das ging nicht ganz spurlos
an den beiden vorbei.)
Bei euch war es so: Du hattest
einen Traum und er kam mit.
Du bist die Chefin und er kommt mit.
Und wir sind nicht im selben Land,
weder in meinem noch in seinem.
In einem eigenen Land.
Wir sind seit zwölf Jahren zusammen.
Und wir sind nicht mehr
so Feuer und Flamme füreinander.
Ich glaube,
wir repräsentieren ein bisschen ...
Nach zehn Ehejahren
geht es den meisten so.
Es verflattert einfach ein bisschen.
Ich glaube schon,
dass wir uns noch lieben.
Sagen wir mal, wir sind eine super
gut funktionierende Familie.- Ja.
(Romantisch klingt das
vermutlich nicht, aber ehrlich.)
(Man spürt, dass die beiden
auch ohne Schmetterlinge im Bauch
noch eng verbunden sind.)
(Ich zweifle kein bisschen daran,
dass sie noch viele spannende
Projekte vor sich haben.)
* Herzschlag *
Als ich ihn das erste Mal sah ...
Ich wollte mich
nicht unbedingt treffen.
Meine Freundin kannte ihn schon und
sagte, ich solle nicht rumzicken.
Ich sollte mich treffen
und dann sei es ja egal.
Ich sagte: "Okay."
Ich war mega stur.
Ich trug eine graue Hose
und die Schuhe, die ich jetzt trage.
Ich öffnete die Türe: "Ui!" Ich
machte die Türe gleich wieder zu.
Ich trug ein bisschen Make-up auf.
Dann machte ich die Türe auf: "Yes?"
* Rhythmische Musik *
(14 Jahre ist es her, seit Kub zum
ersten Mal vor Claudias Türe stand.)
(Seitdem ist die Zürcherin mit
dem NBA-Basketballprofi zusammen.)
(Lange lebten sie in Miami,
weil Kub bei den Miami Heat
einen Vertrag hatte.)
(Hierhin zieht es Claudia
immer noch oft,
nun aber für ihr eigenes Geschäft.)
(Sie ist
ins Catering-Business eingestiegen.)
* Zarte Gitarrenklänge *
In Miami ist es immer schön warm.
Die Leute sind eigentlich nett.
Fürs Business ist es sehr gut,
weil es viele Athleten gibt,
viele andere Superstars,
die singen oder rappen,
die sich einen Privatkoch
leisten wollen.
Mega cool, all diese herbs.
Look at the basil.
(Claudia kam ursprünglich
nicht wegen der Liebe in die USA.)
(Sie war Zirkusartistin und Tänzerin
und baute sich in den Vereinigten
Staaten eine Karriere auf,
bis am Valentinstag
ein grosser Mann in ihr Leben trat.)
In Amerika
ist das ein grosses Thema.
Alle hatten einen Valentine
und ich war alleine zu Hause
in Los Angeles.
Dann hat Kub
mir wieder einmal geschrieben.
Er hat mir immer
via Myspace geschrieben.
Er hat immer gesagt, als er mich
gesehen habe, habe er gewusst,
dass er mich heiraten wollte,
obwohl wir uns nicht kannten.
Er schrieb mich immer wieder an
und ich schrieb nie zurück.
Ich dachte: "Nein, nein,
so ein grosser, dunkler Mann."
"Lieber nicht."
Und irgendwann habe ich nachgegeben,
zufällig am Valentinstag.
(Ein folgenschwerer Zufall.)
(Die beiden sind
seit über zehn Jahren verheiratet
und haben zwei Töchter.)
Hey!
Schau, wo ich bin.
Happy Valentine's Day!
Alright,
talk to you later, love you.
Bye.
* Rhythmische Klaviermusik *
(Kub, eigentlich Yakhouba Diawara,
ist Basketballprofi.)
(Einer, der es geschafft hat.)
(Aus Frankreich führte ihn
seine Karriere über Italien
bis in die amerikanische NBA,
die beste Liga der Welt.)
(Jetzt, gegen Ende
seiner aktiven Karriere,
könnte noch eine neue Herausforderung
auf ihn warten.)
(Ein Abstecher nach Afrika.)
Ich bin in Frankreich aufgewachsen,
meine Frau ist aus der Schweiz
und meine Kinder
sind in den USA geboren -
wir sind also total gemischt.
Deshalb interessiert mich Afrika,
ein weiterer Kontinent.
Je mehr man sieht,
verschiedene Kulturen,
offen sein gegenüber anderem,
das ist das Beste.
Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass Basketball mir das ermöglicht.
Ich kann mich wirklich
glücklich schätzen.
(Hier in New York
findet so etwas wie ein Casting
für die Mannschaft statt.)
(Eine Chance,
die Kub unbedingt packen will.)
* Unverständliches Gespräch *
(Wie so oft,
ist Yakhouba alleine unterwegs,
weg von seiner Frau Claudia
und seinen beiden Töchtern.)
(Basketball hat das Leben von Ya-
khouba völlig auf den Kopf gestellt.)
(Als Sohn
senegalesischer Einwanderer
ist er in Paris in einfachen
Verhältnissen aufgewachsen.)
(Geldsorgen
sind heute kein Thema mehr.)
(Aber auch das Leben eines Superstars
hat Nachteile.)
Das Blöde ist, man ist immer weg,
hat Zeitverschiebung.
Facetime und Skype sind schon gut,
aber natürlich nicht das Gleiche.
Aber eben, wir haben
dieses Leben selber gewählt.
Uns hat niemand gezwungen.
Wir wussten beide,
worauf wir uns einlassen.
* Herzschlag *
Ich habe nie daran gedacht.
Ich hatte vorher nie eine Partnerin
aus einem anderen Land,
es war nie ein Thema.
Es ist einfach geschehen.
Ich Glücklicher.
Ich hatte auch schon Partner,
die aus einem anderen Land stammten,
aber in der Schweiz lebten.
Damals prallten verschiedene
Mentalitäten aufeinander.
Ich habe diese Erfahrung
also mitgebracht.
Ich habe nie wirklich
negative Erfahrungen
mit anderen Mentalitäten gemacht.
Deshalb war ich
dem gegenüber sehr offen.
* Ruhige Klavierklänge *
(Florence war Flight-Attendant,
arbeitete bis vor Kurzem
als Tierpflegerin
und lebt mit ihrer jüngeren Tochter
Noya in Derendingen.)
(Die ältere Tochter Laura
ist ausgezogen
und kommt nur noch
hin und wieder zu Besuch.)
Das ganze Haus.
- Ja.
Das ist deins?
(Dafür leben in diesem grossen Haus
auch noch sieben Hunde.)
Hallo, hallo.
Man weiss gar nicht,
wo man zuerst hinschauen soll.
Ist ja gut, ist ja gut.
* Jaulen, Bellen *
Ja, so läuft das.
- Wirst du immer so begrüsst?
* Sanfte Klänge *
Wie hat dein Mann reagiert, als er
zum ersten Mal zu dir nach Hause kam?
Er wusste es ja.
Aber er als Nichthundehalter -
er hatte auch noch nie einen Hund -
wusste schon nicht genau,
was auf ihn zukommt.
Aber er sagte, er habe es sich
schlimmer vorgestellt,
als es schlussendlich war.
(Die beiden lernten sich
über Facebook kennen.)
(Er suchte eine
Französisch-Dolmetscherin
und fand die Frau des Lebens.)
Ich bin Mona.
- Hallo, Laura, freut mich.
Noya, freut mich.
- Noya, Mona.
Wie habt ihr reagiert,
als eure Mutter sagte,
dass sie sich
in einen Schweden verliebt habe?
Am Anfang war es ziemlich komisch.
"Oh, jetzt kommt wieder
ein neuer Mann."
Aber als wir uns das erste Mal
sahen, hat es sofort gefunkt.
Wir verstanden uns super,
auch die Sprache war kein Problem.
Fast so, als wäre er Schweizer.
Sie hat ihn uns vorgestellt und wir
haben gemerkt, dass es ernst ist.
Man hat gemerkt,
dass er super zu uns passt.
Er ist gleich wie wir,
hat den gleichen Humor.
Es ist uns wichtig, dass wir
jemanden in der Familie haben,
der zur Familie passt
und mit uns harmoniert.
Wir hatten
keine Startschwierigkeiten.
Dann wohnt ihr hier zu zweit
wie in einer Frauen-WG?
Ja, mehr oder weniger.
Eine Hunde-WG
trifft es vielleicht eher.
Wie sicher ist es,
dass du nach Schweden ziehst?
Aha. Also das ist schon ...
- ... das steht fest?
Das Haus, das Niklas jetzt baut,
ist so konzipiert ...
Es ist mitten im Wald,
ganz abgelegen.
Er sagt immer,
dass er nicht alleine dorthin zieht.
Er rechnet fest damit,
dass du kommst?
Ja, ja.
- Du gehst? In einem Jahr?
Ja, das kommt auf Noya an,
sie macht noch die Lehre.
Nicht mehr ganz anderthalb Jahre.
- Genau.
Es kommt auch darauf an,
wie es ihr sonst geht.
Du hast eine Angststörung,
kann man das so sagen?
Oder wie nennst du es?
- Doch, es ist eine Angststörung.
Wie zeigt sich das bei dir?
Von aussen sieht man es nicht,
ausser wenn ich akute Symptome habe,
z.B. eine Panikattacke.
Zittern, Probleme mit der Atmung.
Solche Dinge.
Erst dann merkt man es,
so zeigt sich die Angst.
Du weisst, dass deine Mutter
nach Schweden zieht -
wie ist das für dich?
Sie hilft mir oft.
Mit Problemen gehe ich zu ihr.
Das wäre sicher seltsam,
alleine zu wohnen.
Aber irgendwann
muss ich damit klarkommen.
Wie ist es für dich? Noya
und du seid sehr eng zusammen,
auch, weil sie diese Ängste hat.
Gleichzeitig weisst du,
dass du in einem Jahr gehen willst.
Wie gehst du damit um?
Das ist ein schwieriges Thema.
Man sieht einen Teenager mit 16, 17,
in seiner unbeschwerten Zeit,
der sich noch nicht viele Gedanken
und Sorgen machen müsste.
Und dann sieht man, wie sie
durch die Ängste blockiert ist.
Das ist hart als Mutter,
wenn man das sieht.
Man überlegt sich schon,
wie das in Zukunft sein könnte.
Wie kann sie damit umgehen?
Gibt es irgendwann ... eine Heilung?
Oder eher nicht?
Wie wird es für sie?
Das steht immer im Raum,
darüber macht man sich Gedanken.
Ich frage mich auch:
"Bin ich eine schlechte Mutter,
wenn ich trotzdem gehe?"
Für mich muss eine Lösung da sein,
bevor ich gehe.
Lösung klingt etwas blöd ...
Für Noya muss es stimmen.
* Brutzeln *
* Winseln *
* Perlende Klänge *
Danke fürs Kochen helfen.
* Herzschlag *
Ich habe damals das Tanzen und
Singen aufgegeben, den Zirkus -
sozusagen eigentlich alles, was
ich war, um Spielerfrau zu werden.
Oder Spielergirlfriend
oder was auch immer sie sagen.
Eigentlich mein ganzes Leben,
das ich kannte.
* Gemütliche Musik *
Was Claudia Diawara ursprünglich
nach Nordamerika brachte,
hat überhaupt nichts mit Catering
oder Kochen zu tun.
Sondern mit einem
ganz grossen Kindheitstraum,
den sie verwirklichen wollte:
mit dem Zirkus.
(Nach ihren Anfängen in der Schweiz
besuchte Claudia mit 18
die Zirkusschule des Cirque du Soleil
in Montreal.)
* Funkige Klänge *
(Den Traum einer Karriere
als Artistin
musste Claudia
wegen einer Knieverletzung aufgeben.)
(Dafür hat sie in Amerika Kub, den
Mann ihres Lebens, kennengelernt.)
(Die beiden machten kurzentschlossen
Nägel mit Köpfen.)
Am Morgen ging ich ins Gym
und meine Freunde fragten,
was wir anschliessend machen.
Und ich sagte: "Ach, ich heirate."
"Heute?"
Ich antwortete: "Ja, heute."
"Hast du ein Kleid?"
Und ich: "Nein."
Wo trifft man am Samstagmorgen
eine sportbegeisterte Familie?
Auf dem Trainingsplatz.
Are you ready?
* Funkige Klänge *
Too low.
* Funkige Gitarrenriffs *
* Hupen *
Hier trifft man euch.
- Hallo.- Ich bin Mona.
Hallo Mona, Claudia.
- Hallo, Claudia, das freut mich.
Alessia.
- Hello, I'm Mona, nice to meet you.
Hi.- How are you doing? Yakhouba.
- Good to see you, I'm Mona.
Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you, too.
Hi, you're Ariana. How is it going?
- Yes.- Good?
(Ich weiss zwar, dass sich die beiden
in Los Angeles kennengelernt haben,
aber was war es genau,
das den 2-m-Mann am Anfang
so fasziniert hat an Claudia?)
... that you said: "She's the one."
Zuerst fielen mir
ihre coolen Hosen auf.
Sie trug Männerjeans,
wie eine Hip-Hop-Musikerin.
Sie trug einen Hoodie
und diese UGG-Boots.
UGG-Boots?
Ja, die UGG-Boots
und so grosse Schlabberhosen.
Viel zu gross,
ich war damals sehr dünn.
Du hast nicht alles gemacht,
um ihm zu gefallen.
Nein.
- Um es mal so zu sagen.
Ich wollte eigentlich
kein Date mit ihm.
Aber alle sagten, er sei so nett.
Ich sagte: "Ja, okay, pff."
Ich habe mich
nicht extra schön gemacht.
Sie wollte gar kein Date mit dir.
Nein.
Blöd für dich.
Blöd für sie.
Wie hast du es geschafft,
sie umzustimmen?
Wir haben anfangs
miteinander geplaudert,
ihre Freunde hatten von ihr erzählt,
wir haben uns wieder getroffen.
Dann fingen wir an,
mehr miteinander zu sprechen,
erzählten einander von Paris,
von Zürich.
Es half mir, dass sie französisch
sprach, wie ich.
Weshalb seid ihr jetzt zusammen
und habt Kinder?
Wir haben uns gut verstanden
und immer mehr geredet.
Es hat sich so ergeben.
Schlussendlich
bin ich nach Denver gezogen.
Für ihn?
-Ja, für ihn.
(Denver, Miami, Atlanta
und zwischendurch
immer wieder Besuche
in der Schweiz und in Frankreich.)
(Familie Diawara
führt ein internationales Leben.)
Er spielte schon in der NBA.
Hast du überhaupt realisiert,
welchen Stellenwert das hier hat?
Nein, da ich aus der Schweiz bin,
wusste ich nicht,
was ein NBA-Spieler
oder ein professioneller Athlet ist.
Das sagte mir nichts.
Ich kenne Hockey und all das, aber
nicht die Ausmasse hier in Amerika.
Das wusste ich überhaupt nicht.
Als ich da reinrutschte,
dachte ich nur: "Ui, ui."
Ich musste erst lernen,
wie das geht.
Fandest du es anziehend,
dass sie eben kein Fan war?
Ja, sie kannte das nicht,
und das war gut.
Sie war nicht wie diese Leute,
die genau wissen,
was du tust und voller Bewunderung
zu dir kommen.
Nur so kannst du
die wahre Person sehen.
Ob du jemanden wirklich magst,
so wie er ist.
Und nicht, weil er der ist,
den die Leute im Fernsehen sehen.
* Gemütliche Musik *
* Herzschlag *
Für ihn war von Anfang an klar,
dass er für eine Weile
in die Schweiz kommen möchte.
Daher hat sich die Frage nicht gross
gestellt, wo wir zuerst leben.
Es war klar,
dass das die Schweiz sein würde.
Dass wir aber Australien auch mal
ausprobieren wollten, war klar.
Das wussten wir.
Wir wussten aber nicht wann,
und wie lange wir
in der Schweiz sein würden.
Das war alles noch etwas offen.
* Sanfte, erwartungsvolle Klänge *
(Am Mittwoch, 18. März 2020,
geht es bei Martina und Cahil
plötzlich schnell.)
(Vor 24 Std. haben sie ihren Flug
nach Australien vorverlegt,
weil es nicht mehr anders ging.)
Es ist jetzt
eine sehr überstürzte Abreise.
Wir haben ...
Das Coronavirus
ist gerade sehr aktuell.
Wir haben uns viele Gedanken
gemacht, was wir tun sollen.
Ob wir schon früher gehen sollen.
Wir haben den Flug zuerst
auf eine Woche vorher umgebucht.
Wir merkten aber, dass das
nicht reicht, um noch auszureisen.
Und vielleicht auch nicht,
um in Australien einzureisen.
Gestern haben wir entschieden,
dass wir heute fliegen.
(Ob sie noch bis Australien kommen
und wie gross die Ansteckungsgefahr
im Flieger ist: lauter Fragezeichen.)
Für uns war es sehr wichtig,
dass wir jetzt gehen konnten.
Es ist alles gekündigt, verkauft,
geplant auf diesen Monat.
Es wäre hart gewesen,
wenn es um ein halbes Jahr
verschoben worden wäre.
Wir planen das
seit eineinhalb Jahren.
Es wäre viel den Bach runter,
würde ich sagen.
(Eigentlich wollte das junge Paar
erst an Ostern auswandern.)
(Jetzt blieb keine Zeit mehr,
um sich richtig von Freunden
und Bekannten zu verabschieden.)
(Immerhin ist die ganze Familie
zum Flughafen mitgekommen.)
Für uns ist es auch
wie nach Hause reisen.
Ah. Oh nein,
wir wollten nebeneinander sitzen.
Sorry, danke, dass Sie das erwähnen.
Vielen Dank.
- (Frau) Eine gute Reise!
Danke, gleichfalls.
Habt ihr euch
hintereinander gebucht?
Oh mein Gott, Gotti.
Jetzt muss ich heulen.
Dürfen wir?
* Wimmern *
(Unter Tränen)
Du bist ja wahnsinnig.
(Für einen Augenblick und eine
innige Umarmung ist Corona weit weg.)
Du gehörst jetzt wirklich
zur Familie.
Hast du mich mal gesehen,
meine Augen sind so geschwollen
vom vielen Weinen.
Wir sehen auch ungekämmt gut aus.
Was meinst du,
wie wir in sechs Wochen aussehen.
Du siehst ungekämmt sowieso gut aus.
- Wenigstens mit dem Rasierer ...
* Melancholische Klavierklänge *
* Unverständliche Worte *
Also, mach's gut, mein Schatz.
Pass auf dich auf.
Ich hab dich so lieb.
- Ich dich auch.
Tschüss.
(Und dann gibt es kein Zurück mehr.)
(Melanie und Martina,
die unzertrennlichen Zwillinge,
haben schon bald
die ganze Weltkugel zwischen sich.)
Du wirst mir fehlen.
Ich kann mir
gar nicht vorstellen ...
... dass du nicht mehr da bist.
* Tränenersticktes Gespräch *
Tschüss.
* Gefühlvolle Klavierklänge *
Natürlich war ich sehr nervös,
als ich dich damals
am Flughafen abgeholt habe.
Wir dachten: "Oh mein Gott,
wir haben nun das gleiche
Hotelzimmer für drei Tage."
"Was ist, wenn es nicht klappt?"
"Was ist, wenn wir uns
miserabel fühlen
und am liebsten sofort wieder
nach Hause gehen würden?"
Wir entschieden uns dafür,
es locker zu nehmen
und einfach die Tage zu geniessen.
Wir verabredeten auch, dass wir,
wenn wir uns am Flughafen sehen,
mal gar nichts sagen würden
bis zum Mittagessen.
Und erst beim Mittagessen sprachen
wir darüber, wie wir uns fühlen.
Genau so machten
wir es dann.
Yes, so we did.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
(Die zwei kennen sich
seit zwei Jahren.)
(Letzten Juni heirateten sie.)
(Florence ist in Jönköping
schon etwas heimisch geworden.)
(Dabei halfen auch Niklas' Freunde.)
* Stimmengewirr *
* Sie spricht schwedisch. *
Ah, vegeterian.
- Very vegetarian.
* Lachen *
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge,
Stimmengewirr *
* Sanfte Musik *
(Eigentlich wohnt Niklas
an einem wunderbaren Ort,
hier in Jönköping in Smaland.)
Im Sommer ist es traumhaft,
dann hat man wirklich Meer-Feeling.
Auch wenn es nur ein See ist.
Am Sandstrand liegen und baden ...
Da hat man schon jedes Mal
ein schönes Ferien-Feeling.
* Lachen *
Hello.
(Aber weil Florence nur in Kombina-
tion mit sieben Hunden zu haben ist,
dürfte die Zeit am Stadtstrand
bald passé sein.)
(Niklas baut an der Zukunft.)
(Die liegt eine halbe Autostunde
weg von hier.)
Das ist unser Dörfchen.
Eins, zwei, drei.
(Etwas Stolz, etwas Aufregung,
ein paar Fragezeichen
und viel Vorfreude sind
bei Florence und Niklas zu spüren,
wenn sie ihr zukünftiges Zuhause
besuchen.)
Wow.
Your new home.
Hier ist der Eingang.
So, wir stehen im Haus.
- Yes.
Wir sind in der Halle.
Das wird die Hundedusche.
Hier kommst du dann rein, bringst
die Hunde rein, voller Dreck,
du bringst sie bis hierher.
Da gibt's eine Art Badewanne
für die Hunde, du steckst sie rein.
Duschen, abwaschen ...
Dann können sie ins Haus.
* Lachen *
Dafür liebt sie mich!
Weil ich solche Sachen mache.
Yes, that's why I love you,
because you do stuff like this.
Und hier ist deine,
Wasch... äh, unsere Waschmaschine.
Our ... It's my machine.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Es ist für mich keine Einsamkeit
in der Natur.
Im Gegenteil:
Ich habe das Gefühl, man ist hier
fast in besserer Gesellschaft.
In der Gesellschaft der Natur.
Man hört die Vögel zwitschern,
Niklas sagte, dass letzte Woche
unten auf dem Feld Elche waren.
Wildschweine sind vorbeigerannt.
Wir werden unsere Hunde
und Tiere haben.
Nein. Ich habe mir oft
die Frage gestellt,
wie es ist, wenn man wirklich
hier draussen lebt.
Wenn ich heute hier stehe, muss
ich sagen: "Nein, überhaupt nicht."
Es ist eher ...
Es ist keine Einsamkeit,
es ist ein Frieden.
It's very peaceful.
- It's peaceful.
* Friedliche Musik *
* Herzschlag *
Liebe bedeutet sehr viel.
Aber am Ende muss man glücklich sein
und schauen,
was für sich selbst das Beste ist.
Dass man selbst glücklich ist
und nicht nur schaut,
dass es allen anderen
und dem Partner gut geht.
Es muss einem selbst gut gehen,
damit es allen anderen gut geht.
* Funkige Klänge *
(Hin und weg war sie.)
(So, dass Claudia aus Zürich
vor über zehn Jahren
definitiv nach Amerika zog,
um mit Yakhouba aus Paris zu leben.)
(Seither sind noch zwei Mädchen
dazugekommen: Ariana und Alessia.)
You pull it out?
- No, my turn!
Rock, paper, scissors, shoot!
- I win again, so I'm first.
(Der ehemalige Profibasketballer
ist inzwischen
ein brauchbarer Hausmann geworden.)
No, you do it wrong!
- Okay, do it again!
Kann er kochen?
- Ja, wirklich.
Er kann kochen.
Aber von dir gelernt?
- Ja, von mir gelernt.
Er kann nur Pizza,
Spaghetti und Risotto.
Including the pizza dough.
- Yeah, pizza dough.
Wie ist das?
Vorher hast du alles geschmissen.
Viele haben Mühe,
den Haushalt abzugeben.
War das bei dir nie ein Thema?
Ich finde es super.
Ich komme jeweils gar nicht heim.
Nur wegen der Kinder.
I don't want it.
- ... prepare.
Es ist gut,
er macht's gut mit den Kindern.
Manchmal gibt es
Meinungsverschiedenheiten,
was sie dürfen und was nicht.
- Du bist strenger?- Ja.
(Streng ist Profiköchin Claudia
auch mit ihrem Ehemann Kub.)
(Aber der nimmt's locker.)
Yes, good job.
Oh, yeah!
- I'm a natural.
Rise and shine.
("Rise and shine"
hat auch gut zu Claudia gepasst.)
(Schon mit 18 ging sie
als Zirkusartistin in die USA,
performte später als Profitänzerin
für Stars wie Jay-Z oder Destiny's
Child, sang selber in Musikvideos.)
# I want it, baby. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
* Rhythmische Musik *
(Yakhouba Diawara
spielte auf seinem Karrierehöhepunkt
bei den Miami Heats in der NBA.)
(Der Sohn senegalesischer Einwanderer
wuchs in den Pariser Banlieus
in einfachsten Verhältnissen auf.)
Basketball
hat mich eigentlich gerettet.
Wenn ich nicht Sport getrieben
hätte, wäre ich wohl noch dort.
Meine Mutter hat mir beigebracht,
zu tun, was man tun möchte.
Sie war eine Krampferin.
Sie und mein Vater standen immer um
5 Uhr auf, um nach Paris zu fahren,
um dort Läden zu putzen.
Mein Vater arbeitete
als Strassenreiniger.
Es war immer mein Traum,
mit dem Sport
so viel Geld zu verdienen,
dass sie nicht mehr arbeiten müssen.
Das habe ich gemacht.
(Kub und Claudia
gingen beide sehr jung
aus Europa allein nach Amerika,
um grosse Träume zu verwirklichen.)
(Das habe sie von Anfang an
miteinander verbunden.)
Du hast getanzt, in Videos,
hast dir eine Karriere aufgebaut.
Dann hast du ihn kennengelernt
und gemerkt,
dass du alles aufgeben musst, wenn
du mit ihm zusammen sein willst.
Am Anfang versuchte ich,
weiter zu machen, was ich machte:
tanzen, singen, turnen, Zirkus.
Aber es ging nicht.
Wir sahen uns nicht.
Eine Spielerfrau
muss immer bei ihrem Mann sein,
denn es gibt so viel zu tun -
was ich nicht wusste.
Man hat so viele Verpflichtungen.
Was denn?
Die Sporttasche hinter ihm hertragen?
Man muss immer schauen,
dass sie alles haben,
dass das Essen da ist,
wenn sie essen müssen,
dass sie ausruhen können,
keine Anrufe kommen, wenn sie ...
Hat man dafür keine Manager oder so?
Muss das wirklich ...
Doch, aber es wird halt
immer alles gemacht für sie.
Sie sind es gewohnt, dass sich
alle auf alle Seiten biegen.
Die Frauen ... Ich glaube, das ist,
um sie auch etwas zu beschäftigen.
Wir hatten oft irgendeinen Luncheon,
man muss da hin und sich anhören,
was sie alles sagen,
dann gibt es Silence Auctions,
wo man Täschchen oder so
billiger kaufen kann,
oder irgendeinen Retreat,
wo die Frauen hin müssen,
oder NBA Care,
da muss man Dinge ins Homeless
oder Women's Shelter bringen.
Man muss zu all den Spielerfrauen-
Events und immer gut aussehen.
Man muss eigentlich
die Identität verlieren.
Es heisst immer: "Ah,
das ist die Frau von Blablabla."
Ich so:
"Hello, I got a career, too!"
Und doch hast du alles aufgegeben.
Warum?
Natürlich für ihn, für uns,
für unsere Zukunft
und was wir für unsere Familie
erreichen wollten.
Ich merkte:
Ich muss da sein.
So viele Frauen wollten
mit meinem Mann zusammen sein.
Wenn ich nicht da bin
oder eine Minute nicht aufpasse,
kommen sie aus allen Löchern.
Wir nennen sie mushrooms.
Sie kommen
so schnell zum Boden raus.
Ich musste da sein, um aufzupassen.
* Tragende Gitarrenklänge *
(Heute begleite ich Claudia
zur Arbeit.)
(Sie ist Private Chef,
also Privatköchin.)
(Ich habe ehrlich gesagt
keine Ahnung, was mich erwartet.)
* Tragende Gitarrenklänge *
Wohin gehen wir jetzt?
Wir gehen zu meinem Kunden.
Er ist gerade im Training.
Wir kochen für ihn,
lassen das Essen für ihn dort,
und wenn er nach Hause kommt,
wärmt er es für sich auf.
Ja.
- Mhm.
Und er ist ... Was macht er?
Er ist professioneller
Footballspieler.
Also ein richtiger rich guy?
Ja, einfach einer dieser Spieler.
Auch ein Athlet, wie Kub.
Du machst das v.a. für Profisportler?
Eigentlich nur Profisportler
oder andere high end clients.
Wir - ich habe mehrere Chefs,
also Köche, die unter mir arbeiten.
Sie sind bei mir angestellt
und ich vermittle sie,
denn ich kann nicht alle Kunden
selber annehmen.
In Florida und Atlanta.
Ein paar Kunden
wollen explizit mich,
und bei ihnen zu Hause koche ich,
so oft ich kann.
Jetzt kommen dann
die schöneren Häuser.
Das ist das Villenviertel?
Das ist der hintere Teil
von Roswell,
wo sehr viele Athleten wohnen.
Da kommt ein grosses, schau!
- Oh, ja.
Das ist kein Parlamentsgebäude, gell.
* Claudia lacht. *
Das ist ein Privathaus.
- Das kannst du kaufen, Mona.
Das hier ist es?
- Das hier, ja.
Das hier? Oh.
(Dass in Amerika alles etwas grösser
ist, weiss man ja eigentlich.)
(Aber ein Basketballfeld auf dem
Vorplatz hat auch hier nicht jeder.)
Hast du einen Schlüssel oder wie?
- Ich habe einen Geheimcode.
* Mona lacht. *
Das sind alles seine?
Das sind alles seine. Er hat noch
mehr, aber die sind nicht hier.
* Dynamische Musik *
Ich habe fast ein wenig Angst,
jemand schiesst gleich auf uns.
Nein, er weiss, dass wir hier sind.
Das ist die Küche.
Ich mache Licht.
Hier drin ... Ja.
Ein begehbarer Esswarenschrank!
Ja. Wir stellen
immer alles schön aus.
Hier sind all meine Messer.
Hier ist noch mehr ... ähm, Gewürz.
Alle Pastasorten, die ich habe.
Ich dachte immer,
das höchste der Gefühle
sei ein begehbarer Schuh-
oder Kleiderschrank für Frauen.
Aber dass es begehbare
Vorratsschränke gibt ...
Wir stellen eben
immer gern alles aus,
und er mag das auch.
Ich finde es cool,
wenn wir immer sehen, was wir haben.
Irgendjemand hat mein Gewürz
durcheinandergebracht.
Aber sonst ...
Aber das ist nicht nur so
ausgestellt, er lebt hier so?
Ja, er kann eigentlich auch kochen,
will einfach nicht.
Und er mag es,
ab und zu eine Frau hier zu haben,
weil er meist allein
in diesem riesigen Haus ist.
Okay. Dann seid ihr
fast ein wenig befreundet?
Ja, schon. Aber ich arbeite für ihn.
Man muss immer aufpassen, man kann
nicht zu nah befreundet sein.
Es kann nicht wirklich
eine Freundschaft entstehen.
Oder sollte nicht.
Klar kann es passieren.
Aber es ist besser,
es professionell zu behalten.
Sonst wird es schwierig
mit dem Arbeiten und der Bezahlung.
Man muss eine Balance finden.
Wie macht man das?
- Klare Grenzen setzen.
Von dir aus auch?
- Ja.
Man kann schon mal zu einem Spiel
gehen oder mal zusammen ausgehen,
aber nicht regelmässig.
Man muss immer daran denken -
das ist wichtig -,
dass man für ihn arbeitet
und nicht Teil der Entourage
oder der Familie ist.
Ich muss ein Messer rausnehmen.
Wie alt ist er?
- Er ist 30.
Das ist eigentlich schon ...
Mitte Karriere. Oder fast Ende.
Nein, Anfangs ...- Aha.
- Irgendwie schon noch.
(Während Claudia
das Essen bereitmacht,
kümmert sich Kub
zu Hause um die Kinder.)
(Als wandelnder Kletterbaum.)
(Für etwas hat man schliesslich
einen 2 m grossen Papi.)
Jackfruit.
Wie hat er sich
in diese Rolle hineingefunden?
Ähm, er ist eigentlich
reingerutscht, also musste einfach.
Off season hatte er ja jeweils ...
... nichts, keinen Job, er musste
auf den neuen Vertrag warten.
Ich begann zu arbeiten
und sagte dann:
"Ich arbeite jetzt,
du musst jetzt zu Hause bleiben."
"Du kannst nicht irgendwo hingehen."
Er musste ein paar Verträge
deswegen auch absagen.
Okay.
Habt ihr manchmal
auch Diskussionen deswegen?
Nein. Er findet es toll, er ist
sehr stolz. Das ist mega herzig.
Stolz auf dich?
- Stolz auf mich. Ja. Das ist cool.
Hättest du gedacht,
dass er das so packt?
Du hast ihn in einem
ganz anderen Setting kennengelernt.
Alles drehte sich immer um ihn.
Er findet es cool.
Wie er sagte:
Früher hat er uns immer Tickets
von Kollegen gegeben.
Jetzt bekomme ich ständig Tickets
für Games oder Partys.
Nicht mehr er.
Und er hat kein Problem damit,
dass du bread winner bist
und das Geld nach Hause bringst?
- Nein. Er gibt's gern aus.
Ach ja? Wofür?
- Für Kinderspielsachen.
Immer, wenn ich heimkomme,
ist da ein neuer Spielwarenladen.
Dann gibt es grosse Diskussionen.
Weil du findest ...
Ich verdiene schon gut, aber nicht
so gut wie er, als er spielte.
Ich verdiene genug zum Leben.
Du kochst immer
hier in dieser Küche?
Nein, es gibt drei Küchen.
Ich koche meistens hier.
Samstag und Sonntag koche ich oben,
bei seinem Zimmer
ist eine sehr schöne Küche.
Und wenn es viele Leute hat,
koche ich unten.
Wir können es uns anschauen.
Wir dürfen uns hier bewegen?
Eben. Manchmal koche ich
in der Küche hier unten.
Hier sind ein paar seiner Shirts.
Mit denen er gespielt hat.
Okay. Das ist seine Spielerhöhle.
Hier kannst du Golf spielen.
Sicher nicht.
Da hinten kochen wir manchmal.
Das ist ja noch mal eine riesige ...
Wenn wir Partys oder so haben, koche
ich hier oder wärme das Zeug auf.
Sie sind dann
meistens im Movie Theater.
Das ist da drüben.
- Das ist sein Kino.
Sein privates Kino.
Ich krieg mich nicht mehr ein.
Und dann? Kommen Freunde her
und essen Pommes Chips?
Da hinten ist eine Snack Bar.
Wir füllen die Bonbons und so auf,
machen frisches Popcorn.
Und was ist das für ein Ball?
So cool.
* Dynamische Musik *
* Gemütliche, drollige Musik *
(Vor 48 Std. flogen Martina und Cahil
total überstürzt in Zürich ab.)
(Wegen der Corona-Krise
und der Grenzschliessung
sind sie viel früher aus der Schweiz
weg als ursprünglich geplant.)
(Kein Moment zu früh,
wie sich zeigt.)
* Sanfte, lebhafte Klaviermusik *
(Hier an der australischen Westküste
ist Cahil aufgewachsen.)
(Bis er vor zwei Jahren
zu Martina nach Buochs zog,
hatte er Australien
noch nie verlassen.)
Ah, finally.
Noch 1 Std.,
dann sind wir in Noosa.
Let's do it!
(Schweizerdeutsch)
Hey, das ist ja auch krass:
Deine Mutter hat dir geschrieben,
ab heute um 21 Uhr kämen wir
nicht mehr nach Australien.
Also nur noch Australier.
(Deutsch)
Ja. Und wir sind nur 3 Std. vorher.
Ja, oh mein Gott.
3 Std. später und wir wären
nicht mehr reingekommen.
Puh!
- Wirklich krass.
(Englisch) Meine Mutter
wird sich extrem freuen.
Sie erwarten uns überhaupt nicht.
Ja, die haben keine Ahnung.
Well, this is where it all begins.
- Yeah.
Ich zittere. Ich bin so nervös.
(Die zwei haben niemandem gesagt,
dass sie heute ankommen.)
(Es soll eine Überraschung für
Cahils Eltern und Schwester werden.)
* Ein Hund bellt. *
* Lachen *
* Bellen *
Hey! How are you?
Good.
Überraschung!
How did you do that?
Oh, my goodness!
Hätte ich das gewusst, hätte ich
abgewaschen und mich gekämmt.
We wanted to surprise you guys.
Vater zieht gerade seine Uniform an
und macht sich auf zur Arbeit.
But he's here.
He was just sitting on the deck.
But he needs to leave for work now?
He does.
- Oh, no.
Hey!
How are you doing?
Welche Überraschung!
You snuck up on us!
- Yes.
You guys were worried we wouldn't
make it. We were worried, too!
Die letzten 48 Std.
waren so aufregend.
They said 9 o'clock or something.
- Yes.
Hey, Genie. Oh!
Hey, Gina. Is your daddy home?
Das ist die beste Überraschung
in meinem ganzen Leben.
We're really happy.
See you tomorrow.
Love you, Marty.
So glad we could make that happen.
Ich danke dir ganz fest,
dass du so gut
auf meinen Jungen aufgepasst hast.
Yeah, that's true.
He's a sloppy Aussie and
you are a fine little Swiss girl.
(Ein Happyend nach einer langen
und ungewissen Reise.)
(Und der Start des gemeinsamen Lebens
in Australien in Cahils Heimat.)
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
(Die beiden wollen
Cahils altes Auto restaurieren
und damit durch ganz Australien
reisen.)
(Ob das trotz Corona möglich ist,
ist ungewiss.)
* Herzschlag *
Wir haben Kinder, Familie,
müssen sicherstellen,
dass alle zufrieden sind.
Wir haben eine Vorstellung,
wie wir es machen wollen.
Aber vielleicht
landen wir in einer Sackgasse.
Und natürlich gab es auch Zweifel
daran, ob das alles klappen wird.
(Der Frühling 2020 hat das Leben
auf der ganzen Welt
auf den Kopf gestellt.)
(Auch jenes von Florence und Niklas.)
(Wegen der Coronakrise
sind die regelmässigen Besuche
vorläufig nicht mehr möglich.)
Ja, das stellt uns jetzt
natürlich auf eine harte Probe.
Wir haben uns zuletzt
vor fünf Wochen gesehen.
Im Moment wissen wir nicht,
wann das nächste Mal sein wird.
Das steht jetzt natürlich
einfach in den Sternen.
Wir können nichts planen, nichts ...
Es ist im Moment
relativ schwierig für uns beide.
* Ein Hund bellt. *
* Freizeichen *
Hi.
- Hallo!
Wie geht's dir?
Mir geht's gut. Und dir?
Hast du Stress?
Ja.
- Okay.
Wir haben
mit Corona-Jobs angefangen.
What are Corona-Jobs?
Wir montieren Plexiglas
an Rezeptionen und Kassen.
Stuff like this.
War etwas mit dem Haus heute?
Nein. Heute war niemand dort.
Wie geht's dir im Quarantäneland?
Immer noch gleich.
Still the same.
Ich lasse dich jetzt
zu deinen Corona-Jobs.
Ja. Wir haben
immer noch drei Orte vor uns.
Bist du okay?
Ja. Klar.
Good.
Okay. Bye, bye!
* Sanfte Musik *
Komm her, Max!
Komm her!
* Sie schnalzt. *
Hopp!
(Eine Fernbeziehung als Ehepaar zu
führen ist per se schon schwierig.)
(Aber wenn ein Virus
noch die Grenzen dichtmacht,
möchte man manchmal verzweifeln.)
(Wann sich Florence und Niklas
wieder sehen können,
steht in den Sternen.)
Ja, ja, ja.
* Herzschlag *
Sie ist weder Französin
noch Muslima.
Das war vielleicht ein Problem.
Eigentlich wollte die Familie
jemanden für mich auswählen.
Deine Mama
hatte schon jemanden im Kopf.
Nicht unbedingt.
Eine Mutter halt.
Sie wollen einen immer beschützen.
Erst recht den Jüngsten, ihr Baby.
Am Ende akzeptierte sie
meine Entscheidung.
Jetzt ist es gut.
Also sagen wir, besser.
Much better than before.
Improving a lot, that's good.
* Gemütliche Musik *
To the bench.
Not so fast!
Slow down, Alessia!
(Es ist Sonntag.)
(Familie Diawara
macht einen Ausflug ins Grüne.)
* Claudia lacht. *
(Grillen auf amerikanisch.)
Alright.
Just open it!
- Zündest du den ganzen Sack an?
Look!
Nicht ganz wie in der Pfadi.
"Bag will burn away
and the charcoal ..."
That's what it says, right?
Whoa!
* Sie lacht. *
Behind you.
Not this one, the big one.
No. Small people take small things.
Yeah, you're right.
Wenn du im Ausland
in einer Beziehung lebst,
lässt du deine Familie immer zurück.
Bei dir schon etwa 14 Jahre.
Etwa so. Nein, fast mehr. Ich ging
mit 18 weg. Das sind 22 Jahre.
Ja, du bist mit 18 gegangen
und hast sie zurückgelassen.
Ja, ich lasse sie immer zurück.
Es war schon schwierig,
v.a., als die Kinder klein waren.
Die Kinder kurz zu Mami bringen und
selber etwas machen, lag nicht drin.
Ich muss immer auf die Schulzeit
achten, oder Kub passt auf.
Als Kub nicht da war,
war es schwierig.
Da war ich sozusagen
alleinerziehende Mutter.
(Das hat sich definitiv geändert.)
(Kub ist unterdessen
ein präsenter Vater.)
Is it done yet?
Does Daddy make a good barbecue?
Yes. Better than Mommy, maybe.
Better than mommy?
- Barbecue maybe, yes.
I want Bratwurst and a ...
- Okay, relax. There's other people.
I'll have that one.
Danke vielmals.
(Unterschiede
gibt es viele bei den beiden.)
(Herkunft, Religion, Körpergrösse.)
(Gemeinsamkeiten aber genauso:
Leidenschaft für das, was man macht,
die beiden Kinder
und der Glauben
an die gemeinsame Zukunft.)
Wie sieht eure Zukunft aus?
Siehst du die hier in den USA
oder zurück in der Schweiz?
Zuerst sicher noch etwas hier,
und vielleicht mal in der Schweiz.
Wir wissen es noch nicht genau.
- Wovon hängt das ab?
Es kommt darauf an, ob Kub
auch in der Schweiz arbeiten könnte.
Basketball wird auch in der Schweiz
immer grösser.
Er bekommt jetzt dann
den Schweizer Pass.
Ah!
Du bekommst den Schweizer Pass?
Wir arbeiten dran.
It takes like one year.
Kannst du dir vorstellen,
die USA zu verlassen
und in der Schweiz zu leben?
Warum nicht?
Ich bin ja Europäer.
Vielleicht könnte ich
in Sachen Basketball
etwas Neues in die Schweiz bringen.
Ich könnte den Schweizern
die italienische,
die französische oder auch die
amerikanische Spielweise beibringen.
Ich hab ja überall gespielt.
Das wäre cool. Warum nicht?
Und du würdest
ein Restaurant eröffnen?
Ja, ich würde gern ein Restaurant
eröffnen in der Schweiz.
Wir überlegen zurzeit hin und her,
ob wir sollen oder nicht.
Mal abwarten, mal schauen.
Was würdest du dir für die Zukunft
eurer Familie wünschen?
Dass wir endlich mal
fix irgendwo bleiben
und nicht immer
aus dem Koffer leben müssen
mit einer Garage voller Gerümpel.
Einfach wirklich
unser Zuhause zu finden.
Mein Wunsch war es,
in der NBA zu spielen,
Kinder und eine Frau zu haben.
Nun wünsche ich mir,
alles, was ich gelernt habe,
weitergeben zu können.
Jetzt könnte ich zurückgeben,
was ich bekommen habe.
That would be nice, I think.
("Hin und weg".)
(Für Paare aus verschiedenen Ländern
ist zu Hause immer dort,
wo die Liebe sie hinführt.)
* Romantische Musik:
"Take My Hand" von Martin Villiger
und Adrian Stern *
# It takes me, breaks me,
tears me up inside.
# But when you smile,
your beauty shines so bright.
Ich glaube, die nächsten zwei Wochen
werden lang.
Ist etwas heiss an der Sonne,
findest du auch?
Gehen wir rein?
# Break out the sad songs
and take them on your ride.
# You just don't know
what the future ...
So in vier oder fünf Jahren
ziehen wir weiter.
# Go ahead and take my hand.
# Take me anywhere,
as long as you're there.
# Together we will be.
There she is.
# Forever you and me.
Take my hand.
Obwohl wir
nicht dieselbe Sprache sprechen,
haben wir uns
extrem gut verstanden - nonverbal.
Es war bald einmal ersichtlich,
dass es einen Einfluss
auf mein Leben haben wird.
Es gab keine andere Lösung,
um zusammen zu sein,
als einander das Jawort zu geben.
"Okay." Am nächsten Tag gingen
wir aufs Standesamt und heirateten.
# Together we will be,
forever you and me.
# Take my hand.
("Hin und weg".)
(Wir haben viele Menschen
kennengelernt, die zeigen,
dass Liebe Grenzen und Hindernisse
überwinden kann.)
(Die Sendung ist vorbei - aber
ihre Liebesgeschichten gehen weiter.)
# Together we will be,
forever you and me, take my hand.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Laura Thomann - 2021